- Anytime you watch a Halloween movie,
you know there are going to be Easter eggs
in honor of John Carpenter,
the director of the original "Halloween,"
and creator of that iconic soundtrack.
Scoring movies was not
Carpenter's only musical endeavor.
He also had a band,
which we see covered in the
pub scene in Halloween Kills.
♪ Daddy don't take it hard when you cry ♪
♪ Mama tears you apart, when she lies ♪
They're singing "She
Don't Want You Anymore"
by The Coupe De Villes.
♪ Daddy don't take it hard when you cry. ♪
♪ Mama tears you apart, when she lies. ♪
This band consists of
Carpenter, Nick Castle,
who played Michael Myers in the original
and parts of the new trilogy,
and Tommy Lee Wallace,
the production designer of the original
and director of "Halloween III."
These mermaid triplets were not the only
John Carpenter reference
in this talent show.
♪ I think I'll break
up with my girlfriend ♪
♪ Her antics are queer, I'll admit ♪
♪ Each time I say darling I love you ♪
♪ She tells me that I'm full of sh-- ♪
The song is called "Shaving Cream,"
and it was originally
aired by a radio host
known as Dr. Demento before being released
on a compilation album called
Dr. Demento's Dementia Royale.
In "Halloween" and "Halloween II,"
there's a special on TV
called Dr. Dementia's
horror movie marathon.
- I plan on making popcorn
and watching Doctor Dementia.
Six straight hours of horror movies.
Little Lindsey Wallace
won't know what hit her.
To learn how "Halloween Kills"
answered a question that never
fully made sense in the original,
how Karen shares a connection
with her counterpart
from another timeline, Easter
eggs from the deleted scenes
and all of the Halloween
franchise references,
stick around to the end of this video.
(dramatic music)
Welcome to Things You Missed.
Evil dies tonight.
- [Marion] Evil dies tonight.
- [Tommy] Evil dies tonight!
- [Woman] Evil dies tonight!
- [Brackett] Evil dies tonight!
- [Tommy] Evil dies tonight!
- [Crowd] Evil dies tonight!
- Spoiler alert, he didn't die.
"Halloween Kills: is the direct
sequel to "Halloween" 2018.
David Gordon Green would return to direct
and co-write the screenplay
with Danny McBride and Scott Teems.
As the title would imply,
this entry would focus more on the kills,
but also on returning
characters from the original,
most of whom get killed.
Later in this episode, I'll
be joined by Jimmy Champane
who will talk about the
little details that secretly
set up aspects of the
finale, "Halloween Ends."
Let's get into the Things You Missed.
(soft music)
The opening shot shows us some balloons.
I couldn't help but notice that the colors
are the same colors as
the Letterboxd logo.
Letterboxd is a social media site
where you can log all
the movies you watch,
so it's almost as if
this is a subtle reminder
to log "Halloween Kills" on Letterboxd.
I don't know if this was
actually the intention,
but if it was, it's a
clever way to remind people
to give this movie some free
advertising on social media.
They just might want to do
it at the end next time,
not the beginning.
This shot leads to Cameron
discovering Deputy Hawkins
where we last left him,
injured on the street
in the previous movie.
I'm surprised Cameron
didn't brush this off
as a Halloween prank of some
kind, but lucky for Hawkins,
Cameron is able to get him help.
We flash back to Halloween night in 1978,
where a group of cops meet up in an alley
and Hawkins says he saw Michael
cross through and disappear.
Chronologically, this scene takes place
right after the original "Halloween."
On another timeline, in "Halloween II,"
we see an alternate version
of the events where Michael,
similarly, cuts through
an alley to escape.
As I mentioned in my last video,
Lonnie Elam is a character from
the original, he's this kid,
but here we can also see
the Smith's Grove car
that Michael stole in "Halloween"
now parked outside of the Myers house,
which means at some point
after getting shot by Loomis,
he drove the car back to his home.
There is another clue
that Michael returned home
that can be seen when Hawkins and McCabe
go to investigate the house
and enter Judith's old room.
The right window is now closed.
In "Halloween," we saw Sam
Loomis and Sheriff Brackett
visit the room earlier that same night,
and in that scene, the window was open.
Everything else about this set in Kills
was carefully matched to
the set from "Halloween,"
from the wallpaper to the
broken window on the left
to the exact lamp on Judith's desk,
so this closed window must be a suggestion
that Michael came home and closed it.
Anyone who noticed this
may start to wonder
where the Boogeyman is hiding.
That question would be answered
when he pops out to attack McCabe,
one of the few instances where
we see Michael Myers run.
And if you look closely,
you'll notice he attempts
to strangle the officer
with a length of rope.
This answers a question
that fans have always had
since the original "Halloween."
When Michael broke into
the hardware store,
Sheriff Brackett describes
the items that were stolen.
- All they took was some Halloween masks,
a rope and a couple of knives.
- [Narrator] We see Michael wear the mask.
We see him use the knives, but until now,
we never saw the rope,
though you could say
that it was used to tie Bob
upside down in the closet.
That's what I think the
purpose of the rope was,
but it's cool to see a second
use for it here in Kills.
It was also very clever
writing to have Hawkins
be the one to kill his
partner rather than Michael,
because it means that this
line from "Halloween" 2018
is technically still true.
- [Laurie] Michael Myers
murdered five people.
- If Michael had killed McCabe,
that would have been six.
It would have screwed everything up.
You can sit back down now, CinemaSins.
The flashback scene ends
just as the opening scene
from the original movie did,
with Michael walking outside
and standing in front of his
house with a blank expression,
where the camera pulls back
and he's eventually captured by police.
That takes us to the
opening title sequence,
which features several
burning jack-o'-lanterns
to represent the fire
that Michael was left in
at the end of the last movie.
There are 12 in all, each
progressively more burnt,
perhaps because "Halloween Kills"
is number 12 in the franchise.
If they really wanted to get metaphorical,
they could have made number eight
a pile of poop instead
of a jack-o'-lantern.
The bar where several of our
returning characters convene
is an Irish Pub known as Mick's
with a horseshoe and shamrock on the sign.
This is probably a small
nod to the original
"Halloween" timeline,
which used Celtic lore
to explain Michael's condition.
In "Halloween II," the
source of Michael's power
is the Gaelic festival of Samhain.
- [Loomis] Sam hain.
- [Zac] In "Halloween
III," it is the motivation
for Conal Cochrane's evil plans.
And in "Curse of Michael Myers,"
the dates of Michael's attacks
are tied to constellations
and ancient festivals of Celtic legend.
I go in depth on this lore in each of my
Things You Missed
episodes on those movies,
but for the purposes of "Halloween Kills,"
all you have to know is that
Samhain eventually transformed
into the holiday that
we know as Halloween,
the title of this franchise.
As I mentioned in the
last episode, this couple,
dressed as a nurse and doctor,
briefly appeared in "Halloween" (2018),
likely as a reference to
the original "Halloween II,"
which featured Michael
taking out Dr. Mixter
and his staff of sl*t nurses.
Their names are Vanessa and Marcus.
And Marcus, like in "Halloween" 2018,
can never seem to
remember his stethoscope.
- [Marcus] Wait, hang on, hang on.
I don't have my stethoscope.
Sh*t, I forgot my stethoscope.
- Just as they were teased
in the previous film
before becoming actual characters,
they tease a character coming up
in the next movie "Halloween Ends."
- Yeah, no, that's right.
You're right, stand up for myself.
Tomorrow morning I'm gonna go in there...
- You will punch Dr. Mathis in the face.
- [Zac] Apparently Dr.
Mathis has been casted
and will be a character
in the final installment.
But there's also a more significant detail
about Marcus and Vanessa that you probably
didn't think about the first time though.
(tense music)
(suspenseful music)
In my Things You Missed
episode on "Halloween" 2018,
I talked about how Laurie Strode
tried to reverse the roles
between herself and Michael Myers
to make her the hunter and him the hunted.
To symbolize this switch,
there are many other role
reversals in the movie,
like Allyson and Cameron's
Halloween costumes
being a gender swapped Bonnie and Clyde.
We see the trend continue
here in "Halloween Kills"
with Marcus and Vanessa.
Marcus is dressed as a doctor
and Vanessa as a nurse,
which are the opposite
of their actual jobs.
- I'm a doctor.
My husband's a nurse.
- I should've guessed.
- Another pair of characters
are swapped in a similar fashion.
Big John and Little John
are the current residents
of the Myers House.
At one point, we see them
standing side by side,
and Little John is a lot
taller than Big John.
Unless the names are talking about their-
When the two are eventually
killed by Michael Myers,
they die in the same positions
as the framed photograph
in the upstairs office, but
their places are swapped.
Because "Halloween Kills"
and "Halloween Ends"
both began pre-production
shortly after "Halloween" 2018,
there is a lot more continuity
among the three films
than we've seen before in this franchise.
Being an authority on this franchise,
my friend Jimmy Champane
is the perfect person
to tell you about some of those details
and why some of them are gonna
be important going forward.
- Something that makes this movie feel
like more than the sum of its parts to me
outside of the attention to
detail during the flashback
is how much continuity there is
between "Halloween" 2018
and "Halloween Kills."
There are also other setups
that are supposed to
be significant in Ends.
In Mick's Bar, we see a poster
for the local radio station,
94.9 WURG the Urge with Willie the kid.
Later on, when Mr. Tovoli breaks into
Marcus and Vanessa's car,
we hear the radio DJ say
the same channel name.
- [Announcer] WURG 94.9,
giving you the urge with Willie the Kid.
- This could tie into the big radio tower
we see at various points
throughout Haddonfield
in "Halloween Kills,"
even the 1978 flashback,
which seems to be hinted
at possibly being a part
of "Halloween Ends" in
the commentary track.
- [Jamie Lee Curtis] What are
you up with this radio tower?
Is it it gonna be in the 3rd movie
Dave? - [Judy Greer] Now it's the
only thing I'm going to notice.
- [Green] I don't know...
- [Jimmy] And speaking of Mr. Tivoli,
we see him during the intro
scene of "Halloween" 2018
before Aaron and Dana meet
Michael Myers for the first time.
Before the encounter,
Doctor Sartain mentions
that they should tie their shoes
because he has a fixation with laces.
And then when we see him
in "Halloween Kills,"
there's a quick insert shot where we see
that he is wearing Vans slip-ons.
And then finally, his
umbrella is found in the car.
Sticking with Kills,
Big John and Little John
have a sign tucked away in their office
for Big John and Little John realty.
We also see that same sign when Tommy
is rounding up locals to
hunt down Michael Myers.
And then of course,
there's also a similar ad
on the corkboard by their front door.
This backstory for the
characters works super well
because it explains why they would ever
want to live in the Myers' house.
They probably got it for a
steal because it was vacant
for so long, but I'm just glad
we didn't get a cliche line
about that in the movie like we would
in pretty much any other horror movie,
and it's all given to
us through context clues
with props inside their actual house
and throughout the rest of the movie.
I also personally like it a lot more
than what we got in the original timeline
with John Strode moving
into the Myers house,
"The Myers house", where
he also seems to be running
his own realty business.
Or at the very least, he
probably got a good deal
on the joint from his brother
who is definitely a realtor.
- So in a way, Big John and Little John
are the spiritual
successors to John Strode?
- Yeah, they even share the
similarity of being victims
of Halloween pranks played
by trick-or-treaters.
- Now, you stinking kids
got about three seconds
to get the hell off my property.
One, two-
- Get out of my yard, you little perverts!
(group screaming)
- I never understood why
he calls them perverts.
All they did was steal candy.
But I do kind of understand
why they made a reference
to a character from "Halloween 6:
The Curse of Michael Myers."
It's because "Halloween Kills"
shares a huge similarity
with that movie in that
these are the only two
Halloween films where Tommy
Doyle comes back as an adult.
They actually considered
bringing back Paul Rudd
to play him again, but it
seems like it didn't work out,
probably for the same
reason they didn't want
Laurie's daughter to be named
Jamie in "Halloween" 2018.
It would just be confusing for casual fans
to have strong elements of
another timeline like that.
So instead, they loaded up the movie
with more covert
"Halloween 6" Easter eggs.
- [Laurie] People are afraid.
That is the true curse of Michael.
- Or, you know, not so covert.
Another similarity between
the two adult Tommys
is their weapons.
In Kills, Tommy sticks with
his trusty baseball bat,
despite having access to guns.
This reminds me of the end of Curse
where in the theatrical cut,
Tommy beats down Michael
Myers with a pipe,
which he swings around
like a baseball bat.
I also think the scene where
Tommy breaks Old Huckleberry
off its moorings is symbolic.
All these legacy characters
have waited years and years
in Haddonfield, and now
they'll finally get to jump
into action to fight Michael Myers.
However, many of them would
suffer a similar fate.
This would be the fourth
time Nancy Stephens
was cast to play Marion Chambers.
She was in "H20," "Halloween
II" and, of course,
the original, where she
was attacked by Michael
from the car.
He climbs on top the vehicle
and reaches down to grab her.
This time, he uses the same tactic
by mounting the SUV she's traveling in,
punching through that
passenger side window
and reaching in to get his hands on her,
but this time Nurse
Chambers doesn't make it.
Michael stabs Marcus in the eye,
like what he did to Dr.
Mixter in "Halloween 2,"
then kicks open the car door
on Vanessa for his finest,
and also maybe funniest kill of all time.
Lindsey Wallace has her
own encounter with Michael
shortly after where she's being choked,
but manages to get away
by peeling his mask off.
She probably picked this up from Laurie,
who did just that to escape
Michael's grasp in the original.
One of the kills earlier in
the movie is also a callback.
We meet the ex-firefighter Phil
Larson and his wife, Sondra,
who, by the way, was the
gravekeeper from "Halloween" 2018.
Michael kills Phil by reaching
through the door to grab him.
We've seen him do this a
number of times, most notably,
through the closet in "Halloween"
and through Laurie's front
door in "Halloween" 2018.
While this next one isn't a
kill and isn't Michael Myers,
there is a callback when
Vanessa leaves the bar
and rushes to her car.
We see the windows are all fogged up,
signaling that someone is hiding inside,
just like when Michael stakes out
inside of Annie's car in "Halloween" 1978.
At the end, Allyson falls down the stairs,
just like Laurie did in the original.
Karen stabs Michael with a pitchfork,
just like Michael did to
Spitz in "Halloween 5."
And this guy brings a hockey
stick to fight Michael,
just like the kid at the beginning of H20.
I guess that's still more
reasonable than this lady,
who brings an iron to fight Michael Myers,
a character so great that
fans started calling her
The Iron Maiden of Haddonfield.
- Hi guys, this is Belissa Lea
and I am the Iron Maiden of Haddonfield.
- New "Halloween Ends"
poster just dropped.
In actuality though,
people are going to riot
if she's not in the movie.
At the very least, they
could throw her a cameo
in the news or something in the same way
that Julian got a little
screen time in Kills
after being a popular
character in the last film.
Best case scenario though,
the Iron Maiden rises
from the dead to kill
Michael Myers with her iron.
The mob that the Iron Maiden is seen in
is a continuation of the mob from the bar.
And if we look closely, we can
discover even more secrets.
(tense music)
You know, as far as extras go,
The Iron Maiden of Haddonfield
gets all the support,
but I personally think
the guy who realized
moving to Haddonfield was a huge mistake
deserves some love as well.
He's part of the mob of
vigilantes who come out of the bar
and into town seeking retribution.
In case there was any doubt
that this is, in part,
the same group from the bar,
we've got this lady repping
the Mick's Bar merch.
Buy dat merch.
This group's existence is a reference
to "Halloween 4: Return of Michael Myers,"
where we see a good ol'
group of Illinois boys
storm out of the bar to hunt down Michael,
but they accidentally kill
Ted Hollister instead.
(sad piano music)
What happens here is pretty similar.
In Kills, they go after Mr.
Tivoli, who jumps out the window
to avoid being massacred by the mob.
(sad piano music)
- God damn.
- These new Illinois boys
actually spend most of the
movie chasing the wrong guy.
Between that, the fact
that Officer Hawkins
accidentally shoots his own
partner while aiming for Michael
and this line from Brackett...
- [Brackett] Now he's
turning us into monsters.
- The idea of hysteria and
outrage being just as dangerous
as a serial killer is more
prevalent here than ever before.
This is fitting for a Halloween movie
released in the era of cancel culture.
People even tried to cancel
this movie multiple times.
Yeah, these cancel culture people
are (beep) deranged losers.
Whether it's an intentional
message by the writers
or just a natural product of
trying to portray our society,
I find it fitting that "Halloween Kills"
highlights a societal issue
relevant to the time period,
following in the footsteps
of the original "Halloween,"
which I talked about in my
Halloween Things You Missed.
One thing that can be
confusing for some people
is the Halloween timeline,
or as I sometimes call it,
The Halloween Express, all aboard.
The current timeline includes "Halloween,"
"Halloween" 2018, "Halloween
Kills" and "Halloween Ends."
It does not include
"Halloween II," however.
In the pub scene where
Tommy introduces Lindsey
to the crowd, he mentions
how her babysitter,
Annie, was killed.
The movie shows us a couple
shots of Annie from "Halloween,"
and then curiously, this shot of her
on the stretcher in "Halloween II."
While "Halloween II" is still
not a part of this timeline,
it makes sense that this part of the story
would have happened anyway
on route to "Halloween" 2018.
On a similar note, much
of this movie takes place
at Haddonfield Memorial Hospital,
which shares the same name
and logo as the hospital
in "Halloween II."
But again, I think we can just assume
this hospital already existed,
even if it wasn't shown
in the first movie.
I know this caused a little
bit of confusion for some,
but look at it like this.
In the original,
Laurie had a crush on
this boy named Ben Tramer.
- [Laurie] I'd rather
go out with Ben Tramer.
- [Zac] But in "Halloween II,"
which takes place the same
night, Tramer is killed.
(explosion roaring)
So Tramer died at about 17
years old in that timeline.
However, in Kills, Hawkins
tells the story of one night
when he was out with Laurie at a bar,
but didn't get past first base because...
- I knew you were sweet for Ben Tramer.
- In the US, you have to
be at least 21 years old
to go to a bar, so this
implies that Tramer
at least lived to see 21
and may still be alive,
which I'm sure Jimmy
is very excited about.
(upbeat 80s music)
Now before I get into
the meaning of the ending
and some of the deleted scenes,
there are a few more Easter
eggs I want to talk about,
so let's go back to the beginning.
- [Zac, recording] Anytime
you watch a Halloween movie...
- That's not what I meant.
(cosmic aura)
That is also not what I meant.
I'm taking it back
to the apparently controversial
firefighter scene.
The name on one of the
firefighter's helmets reads Gamby.
Gamby was a character played
by co-writer Danny McBride
when he was on the TV
series Vice Principals.
We can see that the fire
trucks have been painted
to say City of Haddonfield,
but the helmet says WFD,
or Wilmington Fire Department,
the unit from Wilmington,
North Carolina where the movie was filmed.
CinemaSins, you can stand back up now.
That means that the gear they
use is real firefighting gear,
so these E31 helmets are
probably just a coincidence,
not a reference to Halloween
being on October 31st or something.
Actually, later at the bar, if
you look at this man's phone,
you'll see the time is now 12:07,
meaning we have officially
crossed into November first,
so the final 74 minutes
of "Halloween Kills"
don't actually take place on Halloween,
which is another similarity
it shares with "Halloween II,"
where we see the November
sunrise at the end.
Then we see another news
report on WCZD, nice.
They show photos of some
of the victims from 1978,
including Lynda and her boyfriend, Bob.
However, for Bob, they
apparently just Googled
Bob 1970s high school and
found this old yearbook photo
of the actor, Bob Odenkirk.
He is not the one who
played Bob in "Halloween."
That was John Michael Graham.
But it kind of looks like
him, so they went with it.
I don't know why David
Gordon Green thought Googling
Bob 1970s high school
would work, but it did.
Target Halloween decorations, nice.
Zombie American Gothic.
I've done that meme before, nice!
Let's go back to the
kids that pull the prank
on Big John and Little John.
The girl claims there
was a rusty razor blade
in her sister's Halloween candy,
which she got at their house.
If you've seen my
"Halloween" 2018 episode,
you'll recognize that their masks
are the Silver Shamrock masks
from "Halloween III: Season of the Witch."
However, these are not the same kids
that we saw in "Halloween" 2018.
If you look at the Skeleton kid's ribcage,
it's clearly a different costume.
But anyway, the girl claims
there was a rusty razor blade
in her sister's Halloween candy,
which she got at Big John
and Little John's house.
Little John is dressed up as a pirate.
In "Halloween II," a
kid dressed as a pirate
goes to the hospital after
biting into a razor blade.
During the panic at the hospital,
one cop informs the chief that
they have called for backup.
- We've requested backup
officers and medical staff
from Russellville and
Eaton County for support,
but no confirmation.
- I feel like I've probably said this
a million times by now,
but Russellville is a reference
to a line from "Halloween I"
where the gravekeeper
tells a story that happened
in the nearby town of Russellville.
Russellville was a city in Kentucky
near where John Carpenter went to college.
We get another scene with the
two Johns later that morning,
where they hear more
noises outside the house.
- Next time, I'm coming with a pitchfork.
- This is foreshadowing.
I already mentioned it, but
there's a moment towards the end
where Karen saves her daughter
by absolutely impaling
Michael with the pitchfork.
(Karen grunts)
LOL.
The sound effect used even shows us
that it's a real metal pitchfork,
not just a plastic Halloween decoration.
(pitchfork clangs)
There's a scene in the
dining room where Little John
gets spooked by his own reflection,
but in front of the mirror,
there's this guillotine decoration.
This is one of those
things where it could be
just a Halloween decoration,
or it could be a little nod
to the famous beheading scene
from "Halloween H20: 20 Years Later."
I do have Jimmy here still.
I am requiring him to stay
until the end of the video,
even though he already said his part.
Jimmy, what are your thoughts on this?
- Wait, what?
- There's also a glimpse
into the remodeled upstairs bedroom.
This is Judith's old room, and
there's a very similar desk
with a mirror and lamp in
the same corner where Judith
was brushing her hair on
that fatal evening in 1963.
When Little John encounters
The Shape, he says this.
- [Little John] Michael, you've come home.
- Which seems to be an
homage to Loomis' line
in the first film.
- He came home!
- Of course, that wouldn't be
the only classic line that came back.
- You know, it's Halloween.
Everyone's entitled to one good scare.
I also noticed that the street
address of the Myers house
is 709 in this movie.
This confused me, because everyone knows
that the Myers lived at
45 Lampkin Lane, right?
As it turns out, I'm here
to tell you they're wrong.
(tense music)
(foreboding music)
I guess this is kind of one of
those Mandela effect moments.
After seeing the Myers address
was 709 in "Halloween Kills,"
just to be sure, I went back and checked.
And to my surprise, 45
Lampkin Lane was actually
an invention of the
sequel, "Halloween II."
- [Cop] The old Myers
house, 45 Lampkin Lane.
- [Zac] If you look back at
the original "Halloween,"
it's actually 709.
Kinda hard to make it out,
but you can clearly see
701 on the neighbor's house
and you can even kind of make out
the painted over 709 in 1963.
So actually, "Halloween
Kills" got it right
and "Halloween II" got it wrong.
Now let's talk about the ending.
Allyson and Cameron go
into the Myers house
after Cameron's dad,
and Allyson discovers
the death of Little John,
and proceeds to take the knife out of him?
She doesn't need a knife.
She already has a gun.
You don't bring a knife to a gunfight.
You bring a clothing iron.
Lucky for Allyson, she's
saved by her mother,
after which she comments
on the everlasting presence
that The Boogeyman has
branded on their town.
- He'll always be here, won't he?
- Even when we can't see him.
- This line serves as a
parallel to the words of comfort
her mom offers her at the
beginning of the movie.
- Dad's gone.
- He'll always be with us,
even if we can't see him.
- Both of these moments
comment on the tendency
of strong emotions to
have a long lasting power,
one with love and the other with fear.
And both of them come with Allyson
wrapped in her mother's
arms, sitting on the stairs.
Afterwards, we see Karen look up
into the right bedroom
window, Judith's old room,
and she sees the six year old version
of Michael Myers staring out blankly.
This puts her in the same camp
as her counterpart from
the original timeline,
who saw a vision of the young,
costumed Michael in a
reflection at the drugstore.
In an early draft of "Halloween" 2018,
Karen was going to be named Jamie,
just like Laurie's daughter
in the original timeline,
who we meet in "Halloween 4."
However, they decided not to do that,
fearing that it would be too confusing.
But the two versions of Laurie's daughter
do share the experience
of seeing a strange image
of Michael Myers's past.
In January of 2022,
"Halloween Kills" was
released on physical media,
along with an extended cut
that includes a few lengthened
scenes and additional scenes.
The 1978 flashback with
Lonnie Elam now includes
an extra bit of Lonnie walking home
and seeing Michael Myers
peering out from behind a shrub.
This is a reference to the
iconic scene in the original,
where Laurie briefly spots Michael
on the way home from school.
The ending of the extended
cut also brings back elements
of the John Carpenter original.
After Karen is taken out by Michael,
she receives a call on her cell phone.
It's Laurie calling from the hospital,
and she simply hears
the sound of breathing
against a plastic mask
and knows it's Michael.
(breathing)
She knows this because
of the call she received
on Halloween night 40
years ago to this day
after her friend Lynda
was strangled by Michael
and she heard the same sound
over the telephone line.
(breathing)
We are now as close as we will ever be
to the final installment,
"Halloween Ends."
To make sure you're caught
up on all things Halloween
before going into that movie,
make sure you watch
Jimmy's video on the right
and drop him a sub.
I'm sure you will after
watching that video.
As always, I'll be going
in depth with everything
you might have missed in Halloween Ends.
Make sure you don't miss it
by subscribing to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring the deathbell for all notifications,
and I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.